welcome to Baywatch we're flashing in
the summer which means the most
wonderful time of the year summer movies
et has your look at what's sure to make
waves in the theater we're the heart
soul of this very Beach is there a
better movie to be on than Baywatch no
this is where it's at man here's some
shots first diving into the
action-packed Baywatch reboot starring
Dwayne the rock Johnson and Zac Efron as
Mitch and Matt he doesn't necessarily
see eye to eye with Mitch and many
things but no I think he's a prick
yeah I can't stand it rah you suck here
we go
show me the mummy welcome to a new world
she is real ah another reboot coming our
way
The Mummy starring Tom Cruise was the
first blockbuster for Universal Pictures
so it's more in the classic vein of the
original Jackie I'm so sorry were you
still talking but first we hit the high
seas as Jack Sparrow returns in Pirates
of the Caribbean
dead men tell no tales there are new
characters ours gonna bring a new flavor
and a different dimension to one of the
most powerful franchises of all time
then men who tell no tales
[Music]
like pirates transformers is also on its
fifth film of the franchise ETS Cameron
Mathison was first on set Michael Bay
says action and things go boo the
explosions are primed and they are ready
and so are we
for our transformers the last night
exclusive oh man here we go
it gets crazier crazyer this every day
we go on you got Michael Bay you got a
historical landmark I mean what could
possibly go wrong nothing it was nice
knowing you Stonehenge on its third
installment its war for the Planet of
the Apes they must pay Oh amazing how
about something new visually stunning
Valyrian and the city of a thousand
planets has everyone talking I think
it's it's definitely way more epic than
anything I've ever been involved with
you know like even compared to a Spider
Man there are so many more special
effects so many more different worlds
aliens it really is a space opera sub
does speaking a Spider Man it's not
summer without some superheroes Tom
Holland is taking us back to high school
in spider-man homecoming you're the
spider-man no I'm not I'm not this is
just costume this is from ceiling you
have the wrist like down oh I do you do
can we see it well we've working on
different ways of doing it for different
types of wet Oh mom sees it's not just
oh I might have given something away
that um so inside this but what we would
really want to try and grab is grabbing
the web we've never seen anyone it's
always just like it sticks to him so now
we have to grab it and okay so that's
our big thing at the moment
that's our Marvel hero on the DC side
there's Wonder Woman starring gal gadot
no one else will defend the world than I
must have so many amazing
female 1 so now we're bringing Wonder
Woman back it's different in its darker
and I love it
while we normally see Scarlett Johansson
kicking butt as Black Widow in the
Avengers this summer she's bringing the
laughs in rough night all about a
bachelorette party gone wrong the cast
in rough night is just absolutely
outrageous with you know some of the
funniest women working today Ansel
Elgort is baby in Edgar Wright's newest
venture a baby driver so what is it you
do I'm a driver another engine starter
for the whole family
cars three
owen wilson returns as the voice of
Lightning McQueen who was pushed out of
racing after a wreck and starts his road
to come back you'll never be the racer
he was for for more must-sees hitting
theaters this summer check out ET
online.com and hey leave a comment below
letting us know you're number one can't
miss movie
[Music]
you